just days before moscow invaded ukraine
the presidents of china and russia met
in beijing and announced a friendship
without limits but how's that holding up
after the war has dragged on more than
two months with russia denied the quick
victory it wanted would china back away
from moscow if mr putin decided to go
nuclear a question for andy mock senior
research fellow at beijing's center for
china and globalization russia is a part
of europe and its security concerns uh
must to be
uh seriously addressed if there is to be
a sustainable peace
uh in europe but what about the
influential voices in china defying the
official line are there signs the war is
splitting opinion in the ruling
communist party
and beijing's militarization of islands
in the south china sea the americans are
calling it the largest military buildup
since world war ii
is all this a preparation for china to
stage its own invasion of taiwan with
taiwan uh clearly the uh the
government's position has been
a peaceful reunification is the goal
but
uh if
other courses of action became uh
inescapable then that is also on the
table as well all that and more on
conflict zone
[Music]
andy mark welcome to conflict zone
great to be here tim
in the early days of the war you and
others in beijing happily told the world
that china is impartial when it comes to
the conflict in ukraine but last week
your vice foreign minister liu cheng let
the cat out of the bag he said no matter
how the international situation evolves
china will as always strengthen
strategic coordination with the russian
side so basically whatever russia does
right or wrong you've got their back is
that it
well tim i'm not sure i would say at
least speaking for myself happily said
that i would perhaps
say solemnly
we all know how tragic this conflict is
and as far as i know
every
stakeholder that has some interest at
stake around the world would like to see
this
conflict resolved peacefully as quickly
as possible
so
in terms of china's quote-unquote
strategic coordination i think the
chinese side has been uh clear all along
that in this particular conflict uh it
is not taking aside other than to take
the side of a peaceful development for
the entire world so when you talk about
strategic coordination with russia i
think we should look at it from a
broader perspective uh it would be
certainly too narrow to think about it
in terms of the ukrainian conflict we
know that uh earlier
andy if i can just interrupt you there
let me sneakily finish tim and you can
ask your question um that when president
putin was in beijing uh there was a
announced uh a
new kind of partnership so i think that
that is the context we should understand
it i want to come on to that uh
friendship and partnership as you put it
a little later on but china certainly
wasn't neutral when it came to the
judgment in the un's international court
of justice against russia ordering it to
stop its invasion of ukraine only two
out of 15 judges voted against that
ruling russia's of course and china's
again so much for chinese neutrality
well tim again i think that this
conflict is regrettable and should be
ended as quickly as possible but we do
need to look at this in
larger terms my understanding this one
of course i do not speak for the chinese
government
offering only my personal perspective as
uh someone that follows this
professionally
uh is that there is a scene around the
world not just in china and russia but
around the world in africa in south asia
many many other parts of the world a
certain hypocrisy about
uh these quote-unquote human rights and
i think that this is perhaps the lens
that we can uh consider uh what you just
mentioned yeah but i was talking about
the icj's ruling icj rulings as you know
are binding under the un charter and
create international legal obligations
for any party to whom the provisional
measures are addressed does beijing in
your view support russia's refusal to
obey the icj ruling
honestly to i don't know enough about
the details of that to really offer a
comment i think other than
my understanding is that from a
principal's perspective and to promoting
a more just and humane international
order that there are large swaths of the
world that seize a certain hypocrisy in
the existing
way that human rights
principles are applied as you know very
few governments around the world are
buying mr putin's justifications for war
141 countries at the u.n general
assembly deplored in the strongest terms
russia's aggression against ukraine in
violation of the charter of the un and
demanded russia end its invasion and
unconditionally withdraw all its
military forces you commented in march
it really wasn't the whole world on the
side of the u.s and western europe is
that all you have to say about this huge
body of international condemnation
it actually is tim
so again we need to look at uh the
entire world here so uh many many
countries have taken
uh a neutral stand on this um 35 that's
all 35 abstained
35 not 141
condemned that's the many
i think that we have to look at this in
a broader context tim so again when we
look at the continuum of
opposition to
uh russia's actions uh there are a
handful of countries that have condemned
russia have imposed sanctions and
perhaps are looking to do even more so
they've been supplying arms to ukraine
and perhaps looking to even do more
i would say if we look at it in terms of
the population of the world represented
certainly a majority does not take this
maximalist extreme position
certainly most countries i think most
people
oppose this
violence and hopes that it ends very
quickly but also recognizes the
complexity of this situation and
unfortunately in too many mainstream uh
western media outlets this is dismissed
as either russian propaganda or
parroting russian propaganda talking
points and i think that clearly uh is
erroneous you you seem to be clutching
at straws if you ignore the fact that
141 governments condemned russia's
action and just go for the the number of
population in their populations of this
country this was a huge body of world
opinion reflected by those governments
andy mock the remarkable thing is that a
number of highly respected commentators
even in your country
aren't buying the russian version either
voices that your government's strict
censorship still hasn't managed to
silence russian expansionism by force
that was the view of xi yin hong
professor of international relations at
renmin university in beijing
either he's a very brave man or it
suggests there's a split in the
communist party in china over russia's
invasion which is it
shortly tim you're not going to fall for
this trope that
china is this monolithic entity and
there's uniformity of thought
even in the united states there is a
diversity of opinion about uh what's
going on in the ukrainian conflict why
should we be surprised that there are
different voices uh in china because you
have tight censorship andy mock you have
the kind of tight censorship that
doesn't exist in the united states
that's why
oh come on tim um you block foreign
radio and television broadcast they
don't do that in america andy mark let's
let's deal with reality
i think the rules are certainly
different tim
so again i think that um it's a
different system there are different
principles um if we have time i'd
certainly love to
get into at least some of what makes
china's system different from uh those
that are uh so exalted uh in the
english-speaking world um but i think
that
a lot of this again is just western
misinformation so you look at uh
the this trope that goes around the
world especially in elite western
circles that
western tech companies are are blocked
because of censorship if you look a
little bit more closely the reality is
they just choose not to abide by the
laws of china and there are of course
other complicating factors i i don't uh
dispute uh what you're saying is that
the way information is handled in china
all right i don't want to go because
we've got a lot to get through in a
short time in your in your opinion does
beijing plan to help russia evade
western sanctions the way you did after
russia seized crimea is that beijing's
plan this
time well again i certainly cannot speak
for the chinese government uh what i can
say is that
why is it uh all right for the us and
nato to arm the ukrainians while it is
not okay for other countries if they
choose to if they choose to to provide
similar material to russia why is it
okay
for countries to sanction certain other
countries but it's not okay for other
countries to retaliate it seems that if
we are basing an international order on
equality and reciprocity uh if that's
not really a level playing field is it
are you telling me there's an
equivalence between aggression uh
invasion um shooting civilians torture
destroying cities and the defense of a
country are you telling me those are
equivalent things well let me ask who's
the aggressor here in the ukrainian
conflict tim who do you think the
aggressor is well we know who you think
it is because you wrote an op-ed in
march when you claim the only reason an
extended military conflict in ukraine is
possible is because it's been instigated
and perpetuated by the united states
those were your words so america is the
instigator anything that goes wrong is
always the west's fault isn't that it
andy mark you talk about trump's this is
one of your big tropes isn't it
nothing is as categorical as that tim
and let me just uh fine tune a little
bit what you said what i wrote was that
the only reason a military conflict is
possible in ukraine is because of
american and nato uh military supplies
if those suppliers talk about instigated
you said instigated in your opinion
so let me just clarify what i wrote and
what we're talking about how the
conflict was instigated or two separate
things
so um clearly you seem to think that the
russia instigated this military conflict
i think there is a
very legitimate body of evidence that
shows that there are other factors that
precipitated this so if you only look at
you hitting somebody without
showing that you were provoked and
whether you were legitimately provoked
or not i think is a question open for
discussion
but was completely omitted in a lot of
western discourse about this is that
there were precipitating factors okay
you you explained your reasoning in the
comments com some comments you made on
al jazeera you said the u.s has
repeatedly i think not recognized the
legitimacy of russia's security concerns
and this has really exacerbated the
situation it seems that the u.s is
certainly willing to fight russia down
to the last ukrainian that that point is
a pretty outrageous slur by the way but
are you seriously saying it's fine for
russia to invade brutalize execute rape
torture and destroy large parts of
ukraine because putin wasn't taken
seriously by america that's a pretty
grotesque argument isn't it andy mark
well if you think that's grotesque tim
then you must think every uh military
response is grotesque as well again i
think the question is
was there a provocation and was that
provocation uh is this a legitimate
response to that provocation again i
think is a very complicated question
so
we can continue uh talking about this
clearly i have my point of view uh i
think that
as long as we can acknowledge that this
is much more complex than
putin waking up one morning and feeling
that he wanted to
militarily attack uh ukraine uh which is
naive and a simplistic uh way of
understanding this the other thing i
want to say too
tim is that this notion of indivisible
security uh which
relates to the european uh situation is
that
russia is a part of europe and its
security concerns must to be
seriously addressed if there is to be a
sustainable peace
in europe and that this is also uh
something that president c recently
picked up on this idea of indivisible
security is actually something that has
global application and not just european
okay but andy mark how do you know
america didn't listen to russia's
security concerns that's pure russian
propaganda you don't actually know
whether they did listen or not do you
you're not privy to their private
communications or their private meetings
you're just repeating whatever fits
beijing's ideological standpoint aren't
you
well
tim how do you know that they have that
well because mr putin admitted last
november that the west had been
listening to his concerns our recent
warnings have been heard he said and the
effect is noticeable tensions have risen
russia should maintain the tensions as
long as possible our recent warnings
have been heard yes that's why i'm
telling you that
well again um i you're absolutely
correct i'm not privy to these
conversations so i cannot sit here and
tell you that i know that they have not
been addressed
western reporting as well has mentioned
this so again i do not completely
dismiss uh western reporting as being
accurate nor do i categorically blame
the us for everything bad in the world
but i do think again that this is a
complex situation uh there are very well
respected analysts uh
practitioners even on the american side
that have said that uh nato expansion
actions in the ukraine are a provocation
to russia and that one should not be
surprised uh if russia does
respond in some
very undesirable ways and these people
include everything from everyone
from george cannon
uh to henry kissinger uh to
recent u.s
senior policy officials
so this is not
russian propaganda on the talking points
i mean certainly the russians are saying
this uh but they're not making this up
out of thin air tim
much talk recently about what you
alluded to earlier in the interview
about your so-called beijing so-called
unlimited friendship pact with russia
how much influence do you think this
pact gives beijing over moscow
well i think that china russia like the
united states like the eu
are large powerful countries so i think
that it's
uh quite
oversimplifying to think that any one
country can exert uh
un
restrained influence over another i
think certainly uh russia and china
share
common concerns i think that they have
complementary as well as uh compatible
development objectives so
uh and of course we've seen as i'm sure
you know the uh number of meetings that
uh presidents c and putin have had
so clearly uh you think there is not
only a
state-to-state relationship but uh
certainly there seems to be a good
personal relationship as well i i asked
the question because in march your
ambassador to the u.s kin gang said an
interesting thing he said had china
known about the imminent crisis i assume
he meant the invasion we would have done
our best to prevent it and i'm wondering
what beijing's best would have consisted
of what tools does it have at its
disposal or was that just an empty boast
well again tim i think this is a
somewhat provocative framing uh to make
this comparison uh and calling the one
alternative an empty boast
certainly
again
china i think has
uh
influence
with russia as it does with the united
states as it does with the eu
certainly
uh information is vital for sound
decision making uh perhaps uh nowhere
more so than in diplomacy i think that
china has been very consistent and very
clear
saying that it is
for peaceful development and
uh really does you know does not want to
see
uh these types of of actions anywhere uh
but of course we have to recognize too
tim that in this uh anarchic uh global
order as many international relations
theorists describe it you know the
school of realism uh countries have to
rely on self-help and they have to make
the best decisions under limited
information and you know sometimes those
decisions are uh in retrospect don't
turn out to be the best but we live in a
very imperfect world
as far as you're concerned are there red
lines in this friendship
ambassador king gang said on april 19th
there was a bottom line to the
friendship in the form of the un charter
if the u.n is to be believed then russia
has already reached that bottom line by
violating the charter hasn't it so i'm
wondering
does china have specific red lines to
this friendship
again you know i don't think i'm in a
position to say um you know as i can see
it uh as someone that researches and
analyzes
these questions
there are very
important complementarities and
mutualities of interest between
china and russia and i think that the
actions of third countries
do play a role in this
and that this is something that i think
anyone that chooses to look at this
objectively can see well let me put it
more precisely the question none of us
of course knows where this war is going
but if mr putin was serious about using
nuclear weapons and moscow has again in
the last few hours cited the real risk
of nuclear war
would beijing draw the line at that or
would china be happy to go along with a
third world war if that's what its best
friend wanted
yeah i think this is a question tim that
certainly concerns uh
i think many people around the world and
it would be it's generally recognized
that
uh a use of nuclear weapons would be
a very bad thing uh certainly would set
a terrible precedent
but we also need to see though tim that
uh this is not happening in a vacuum
uh
secretary of defense secretary of state
uh austin and lincoln were recently in
ukraine uh there were comments made uh
by the defense secretary uh that
weakening or degrading the russian
military is now seen as an american
objective so again i think we come back
to this idea that
uh is this an unprovoked action or
is there
uh some precipitating event and is that
precipitating event
uh causing a legitimate response or not
i think we don't know
you didn't you didn't answer my question
andy mark as to whether this nuclear war
would be a red line
at which point xi jinping would pick up
the phone to mr putin and say that's too
far we're not going with you on that
well the other way we can interpret this
tim is if the u.s provokes a nuclear
attack
by russia how will the world including
china respond
i think is a
question i hope no one has to answer
but uh you know again to just frame this
you're not going to give me a straight
answer on this are you um let me let me
let me put it another way the the joint
statement issued by your two governments
russia and china in early february
talking of a no limits partnership was
apparently the first time china
explicitly joined russia in opposing any
further nato expansion
if nato is expanding it's because the
threat is expanding russian expansionism
in europe and beijing's increasingly
increasing militarization of the south
china sea can't you understand that
that's a reason why nato is expanding
and why people are looking to join
because they require more protection in
these dangerous uncertain times
well i would agree with the last part of
what you're saying so i'll answer your
question i would say it really depends
and again
if the u.s launched a nuclear attack
against russia and russia retaliated in
kind this would be one situation
if russia that was not provoked and used
a nuclear weapon that would be a
completely different situation i think
we're unfortunately in this gray area
and this is again to to simply answer
your question i would say it depends and
i have no way of knowing
let's talk about the south china sea for
a moment why did why did china break a
specific promise by xi jinping in 2015
not to put military equipment on the
spratly islands he said at the time
relevant construction activity that
china is undertaking does not target or
impact any country and there is no
intention to militarize we now see on
these islands anti-aircraft anti-ship
missiles runways seaports and white
domed radar installations what's that if
not militarization andy mark
well tim again unfortunately or
fortunately we do not live in a static
world um
times change uh interest change in the
promises get broken
well i think uh
again uh times change and i think people
have to adapt countries have to adapt
is your government intending to do to
taiwan what russia is doing to ukraine
is that what all this is about
i think any country especially any large
country uh especially a continental
country with increasingly global
interest i think cannot reduce
its security concerns to a single issue
or to a single dimension
um so when we look at taiwan it of
course is very important to china but
uh
china again has increasingly
complex uh i think security challenges
and i would say also opportunities as
well but
with taiwan uh clearly the
the government's position has been
a peaceful reunification is the goal but
if
other courses of action became
inescapable then that is also on the
table as well and again i think this is
something that no one wants to see and
certainly countries that have an
opportunity to influence this
can uh have a positive impact by
exerting their influence for a peaceful
reunification rather than encouraging
uh
taiwanese
factions to take a course of action that
clearly china has said it cannot
tolerate
andy mark thank you very much indeed
it's been good to have you on conflict
zone thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you